c'est la démonstration d'une faiblesse
du président de la république ça il est
en désaccord il n'a pas su établir de
lien avec les territoires de notre pays
et mon mécaniquement le sénat est
désigné par des grands électeurs que
même remonte aux municipales de 2014
ce sont des femmes et des hommes engagés
qui n'ont pas considéré que les trois
mois de présidence
emmanuel macron justifiait qu il change
d'orientation politique folle une
déception des collectivités locales
compagne de désaccord avec les
collectivités allons plus loin est ce
que vous diriez par exemple que c'est un
désaveu pour le président c'est un
problème d'image c'est un homme des
grandes administrations des grands
services publics de l'état des grandes
banques des grandes métropoles et villes
moyennes des petites villes du monde
reut la ne sait absolument pas senti
couvrir par ce président de la
république
je crois qu'il ya un véritable effort de
compréhension